in the movie blinds that is coming your
way starting today along with Alec
Baldwin and Demi Moore man who plays a
bad man who goes to jail for some
financial hanky-panky and then all of a
sudden hanky-panky breaks out between
his wife and Alec Baldwin Dylan
McDermott good to see you here on you
too good to see you
now it's interesting in in this film
your character is not a very good
individual not a good person at one
point in the scene you see him take a
golf club to somebody's me I'm not
spoiling anything I'm not really good so
I asked you in the commercial break was
that a five iron or six iron and you
said they'd had a little bit more longer
so I used a 9-iron for that I'm going to
hit somebody needs always a 9-iron right
and that led me to ask you if you play
any golf yes would you please go ahead
and do it reveille and you know question
yeah you know animal cast audience Oh in
life you know how it is when you don't
want something you get it in boatloads
mm my dad played golf and my grandfather
played golf and you know they were
always asking me to play and I was like
I'm not sure you know and then one day
MacGregor said hey we want to make you
some clubs I was like sure just because
they liked your analogy here to rich oh
yeah the prices for better like we want
to make you some clubs okay great and
then Nike said we want to dress you I
was like okay cool totally unsolicited
this is coming in we don't want it to
come okay sure and then Tiger Woods
called up and said hey you wanna you
want to play for my charity with Charles
Barkley and Kevin James and I was like
hell yeah let's do this
Wow and then I saw and then Butch Harmon
then Butch Harmon gives me lessons this
is ridiculous I know it's ridiculous the
whole thing everything you know so
you're not in a golf no somebody says
we'll make it clubs that's right Nike
says well McGregor's isn't making clubs
Nike says will dress you and Tiger Woods
just called
ivko charity was he affair up was you a
fan of the practice adjusting he called
for charity okay sure I played with him
and I mean it was unbelievable look to
be on the driving range and to see him
hit that ball was wasn't so you you play
I'm a hugger
yes and who is part of the other
that we had Charles Barkley uh-huh with
that famous hitch it is do not try this
at home but you can't look at it right
you can't you can't look at it okay it
doesn't look good at all but somehow it
goes straight I'm quite sure why but
it's one of those things where yeah it's
like watching a it's like watching
American Horror Story that's right but
yeah I watch it you have to watch your
hand because you don't know Sarah and
Kevin James who is a very good golfer
right I was the worst but I had fun
playing with those guys I really did and
then I retired it's not refundable is it
that is a walk-off yeah that's it I'm
not gonna you can't because then you
can't go playing with your horse what
are you doing right yeah but Sabbat
tiger tell you I mean what's your what
what conversation does one have with
Tiger Woods when one plays golf I mean
the guy is all you know he's just about
winning
he's even that Damon that day he just
wants to win every single shot so now
what what competition was being played
like we did did you have I mean I think
he wanted to be Barkley into the ground
okay which I was right yeah with the
four of us but somehow I think I think
it was maybe me and Kevin James or me
and Barkley we actually beat them how we
did I don't know come on I know for like
for the like I know like that or oh okay
like on it yeah well it was for charity
yeah so I'm sure Tiger let you win yeah
that's Dylan McDermott here on the Rich
Eisen show so you're from the New York
metropolitan area it's rising yeah so
what's your team's what teams are you
know and all the Heartbreakers we got
the we'll start with the Jets which you
know so much pain for so many years yes
Indian continues we continue to bleed
out and as it doesn't look much better
well I mean it's difficult when you're
you're being accused of tanking yeah
the start and and it's the summer that's
right right yep
so you're accused of being not even
competitive for the season yeah and the
season hasn't started yep and the draft
for the season isn't for another ten
months that's kind of leaves a mark yeah
that's I think that's what's wrong with
the system isn't it well usually with
the Jets
yeah and for a long time one would say
who was your guy was it Namath is that
the guy who I mean what else can you
write well what else are we going to
point to I know I mean that's all we
have
I met him a handful of times to the NFL
Network the last time I met him I hugged
him ha ha I did didn't hug me no you did
ha ha bet you met Jeff a union hug no no
well you weren't but uh you're not dylan
willie McDonough's you know I understand
yeah didn't go to Alabama we went to
Fordham again boredom it's all good yeah
where's who is it for them when you were
there is anybody Fordham Rams
turn out some no nobody nobody so you're
jack what else are you you're well too
much you know the cool thing about the
messes I threw out the first pitch how'd
you do strike man write down I was in I
was I was practicing forever where you
really tunnels with my good friend who's
passed away but you know I mean we
worked hard okay we worked hard and you
know that means a lot of pressure I
would just [ __ ] out Citi Field you got
all these people out there and you know
you want to throw it in the dirt you
can't be good
this stuff's on YouTube forever no it's
horrible so you know I did okay and I
felt really good
I just thought based on the golf story
you told me it's like yeah you know I
really wasn't into it but Tom Seaver
called me Seaver called me up he gave up
and that's have been great they always
take care of me when I go to New York
okay yeah mr. met didn't flip you off
did he when you saw him maybe behind my
back I don't know he has only four
fingers but uh you know it's so the
Knicks and Jets cuz you're buildin Ickx
we'll talk about the Knicks okay my god
another mess what is going on they have
all the money in the world but right you
think they could fix it you would I
think they've got the worst owner in
sports quite frankly is that word an
artifice I'm a Phil Jackson I was
Jackson just how do you miss that uh
well he just areas it's just the Knicks
luck that the guy with eleven rings the
arms in and gives you 11 wins in
surrenders essentially I am definitely
rounding down there's those there's no
doubt about that
yeah so tell me about blind that's uh
that's with you and Alec Baldwin and
Demi
more and it's ready for consumption
today today I mean you know what I like
about this movie is that it's a
throwback to the movies that I grew up
in the 70s with you know I just it's a
love story but you never see any more
because we're all too cynical but
there's some violence in it and there's
some grit to it which I like it's that
we kind of New York grit which is cool
and Alec does a great job playing a
blind man and to me you know this is a
you know I guess they didn't move here
years ago together so it's nice to see
them back on screen together and I think
the three of us you know this is a nice
little concoction in this movie okay
that that is kind of compelling do you
like playing bad guys because you never
really used to know I mean I like to mix
it up I'm gonna do a comedy um Will
Ferrell and Adam McKay called LA to
Vegas okay that's my real my real love
this comedy which I never get to do um
so I'm going to do that but I like to
mix it up it like good guys bad guys
yeah movies TV theater I just keep
moving I'm gonna I'm gonna go way back
on your what was it like hamburger hill
was that your first ride horse movie
open call on the streets in New York
what a movie that is yeah hell of a cast
too great cast
Courtney B Vance and Don Cheadle yeah
even Webber yeah let's go there's all
our first movies which one which movie
are you proud of that you think doesn't
get it to do or TV show that you've been
part of ah you know there's a movie
called Wonderland about John Holmes
mm-hmm - people saw I like that movie
because I completely disappear in that
movie you don't even know it's me okay I
like that one that's that's that's a
good one okay yeah well I'm looking
forward to seeing blind and everybody
should go out and see it right right
here right now Jordan today and good
luck to the Jets this year oh good I
need to truly cross every finger and toe
do that I think we're gonna have to I'm
gonna go to a couple games though are
you really oh sure yeah I'll go what's
it like what do you put on your your
Wesley Walker Jersey buddy got you your
your Richard Todd what do you got
going quite sure what I wear you know
got to figure that out
okay maybe where that small helmet I had
and did a small ha with the small on
your jets helmet that's right here that
on my head yeah it's got those Herm
Edwards autograph on the side it's
better than a rich coat I'd there it is
throw it over okay here comes look it is
oh nice grab oh that did look like it
did look like a jet receiver what a Mon
better there you go J cloud J ETS Jets
Jets Jets so Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on radio stations across
the country and audience if you like
that video be sure to download our app
don't have any memory on your phone
let's start to delete some of those
slo-mo videos you have and you know
which ones I'm talking about